yes and actually in the capital
um it was heavily targeted in the
beginning of the invasion when Russian
forces tried and failed in their
lightning strike to seize the capital
but since about March time it's been
relatively quiet in the city life has
been returning to the streets people
returning back to the capital children
going to school again
um and yet today waking we're waking up
to this awful news of these devastating
strikes it would seem explosions for
sure in the center of the city
um the mayor is saying that the center
of the city is largely being closed down
by law enforcement as they respond to
the attacks and as you've said there are
reports of wounded and dead and I'm sure
as the day goes on we'll get more
clarity about where exactly the strikes
hit and who how many people have been
killed and injured but yes it is an
escalation in the war they'd been
um concerns that after that strike after
that those explosions those mysterious
explosions over the weekend against the
bridge that um connects the Crimean
Peninsula that was seized illegally by
Russia back in 2014 and annexed and then
Russia built this
um this large Bridge linking
deliberately that Peninsula with the
Russian Mainland and over the weekend we
saw uh the the news that there'd be this
explosion on the bridge the bridge had
been
um partially destroyed and Russia very
angry accusing Ukraine of that attack
um the Russian president is going to be
meeting with his security officials at a
security council meeting today and
yesterday he had these words on the on
the incident
there's no doubt it was a terrorist act
directed at the destruction of
critically important civilian
infrastructure of the Russian Federation
and the authors perpetrators and those
who ordered it are the special services
of Ukraine
so obviously we don't know for sure if
the attacks today are in direct response
to Russia's anger over what happened to
the bridge but it seems a bit of a
coincidence if they're not linked in
some way there's also concerns that as
well as these obvious strikes Russia
might be looking to hit Ukraine and its
allies asymmetrically using other forms
of
um of hybrid Warfare to cause harm so
people very much on alert for what might
come next